121st Boston Marathon will get underway
in just minutes more than 30,000 runners
are registered nearly 14,000 are women
among them is Catherine switzer 50 years
ago she was the first woman to register
and officially run the race Tom de leurs
at the marathon finish line in Boston's
Copley Square with how Switzer changed
the definition of strength and stamina
in a male-dominated field Don good
morning good morning these days women
March for gender equality in 1967
Catherine Switzer ran but she didn't set
out to break stereotypes or to change
the culture of sports forever but that's
exactly what she did they're using this
as a women's rights photo that you know
she attempted to run the race and he
tried to stop her and she finished
anyway
in 1967 Switzer became the first woman
to officially cross the finish line of
the Boston Marathon
she didn't intend to stand up for
women's rights that day she just wanted
to run when you tied your shoes that
morning you weren't setting out to be a
revolutionary I didn't plan to do
anything but try to cover 26 miles 385
yards nothing in the rulebook prohibited
women from running the Boston Marathon
but few believed they had the physical
stamina to do it people were very very
leery of any arduous activity for a
woman because they thought it would make
her turn into a man Switzer registered
using just her initials she wore baggy
clothes as protection from the snow it
wasn't until the race began that
officials noticed a woman running among
the men all of a sudden I heard a
scraping sound and I turned and I
suddenly looked into the face of the
angriest guy I'd ever seen this guy was
out of control he's snarling at me that
out-of-control guy was one of the race
organizers jock Semple and he grabbed me
and he screamed get the hell out of my
race I was just terrified and he said
give me those numbers give me those I
mean who's went after the one on my back
and as he went for that my burly
boyfriend who was running alongside 235
pound X all-american football player
took out the official just like that and
sent him flying and my coach said run
like hell the moment galvanized switch
and sitter on a new course as an
advocate for women's athletics I was so
terrified and embarrassed and humiliated
but then I said no I've got to finish
this race because if I don't nobody's
gonna believe women should be taken
seriously today at age 70 she's running
for her foundation to 6/1 fearless the
organization named after her now famous
bib number from the 67 marathon aims to
empower women through running you see
running as a metaphor for freedom of
choice it's a transformational
experience and a way to take control of
their own lives and their own destiny as
Switzer embraces her destiny for her
50th anniversary race she's focused on
starting healthy and finishing strong
but if I get near the finish line I look
over there and I see somebody who's got
gray hair and is maybe in my age group
I'm just gonna kick a little but you
still have that fire I tell you you
never lose that you always want to be a
little bit better Switzer and that race
official who tried to pull her off
course actually became close friends
before he passed away and by the way
another woman actually ran the Boston
Marathon a year before Switzer did her
name was Bobby Gibbs but she was not an
official entrant Gail Wow that was a
nice little button at the end that they
actually became friends because I was
thinking that he wasn't thinking I
remember that day so while I remember
that photograph so well because it was
so extraordinarily half of the runners
or women yet so bright and she looks so
good
thank you very much done